[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée avec au menu de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici le programme de ce
28 février
il rouvrira ses portes demain après
plusieurs années de travaux le club le
village à Montigny-le-Bretonneux va
accueillir à nouveau ses adhérents dans
un complexe complètement rénové la
structure gérée par l'UCPA permet
toujours la pratique du tennis du
fitness et du squash mais aussi de
nouvelles disciplines TV 78 vous fait
visiter les lieux en avant-première dans
cette édition
la France championne du monde
d'improvisation junior les jeunes de
Déclic Théâtre ont été sacrés face au
Québec à la Suisse et à la Belgique lors
de la finale du Mondial dimanche devant
une salle comble à la Meurice de Trappes
pendant 4 jours les délégations se sont
affrontés lors de matchs d'impro ou la
bonne humeur prévalait sur le résultat
et puis le festival électrochic revient
pour une septième édition le rendez-vous
de la musique électro se déroulera du 9
au 18 mars dans 8 communes de Versailles
Grand Parc 23 artistes sont à l'affiche
et pour en parler Christine pallaud
directrice de la culture de
l'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc et
Jean-Marie guynebert directeur des
affaires culturelles de la ville de
Versailles qui seront avec nous tout à
l'heure en plateau également avec nous
tout à l'heure les lauréats de la saison
8 du tremplin des voies qui seront avec
nous en plateau la finale qui s'est tenu
il y a quelques jours c'était ta Mani
liamo et aussi il est déjà installé lui
en plateau cette Frédéric Rieu bonsoir
bonsoir responsable des animations de
l'équipe animation à la Bergerie
nationale on va parler avec vous d'un
spectacle immersif qui va nous plonger
dans le quotidien des bergers en tout
cas de la formation de bergers dans les
années 30 on en parlera tout à l'heure
c'est un sujet aussi forcément
d'actualité en ce moment avec le salon
de l'agriculture et c'est aussi en ce
moment à la Bergerie Nationale
l'enquête on peut mener l'enquête en ce
moment du côté de la Bergerie Nationale
effectivement nous terminons du coup la
deuxième semaine des vacances avec des
enfants qui viennent passer l'après-midi
avec parents au grand-parents pour mener
une enquête et résoudre un souci qui
leur expliquera les fondements du coup
d'une agriculture respectueuse de
l'environnement des du bien-être animal
et du consommateur on en dit plus dans
un instant en face de vous comme tous
les mardis il y a Véronique Ithurbide
bonsoir bonsoir qui vient nous parler de
ces insolites c'est ces informations qui
ont peut-être échappé à noter les
spectateurs quel est le menu du jour
alors il y a trois à trois sujets vous
avez Epico
je vous dis parce que c'est
la start-up néoplante et
l'avant-première du documentaire de
Xavier de Lausanne en liberté et puis
quoi vous avez fait retravailler ma
prononciation en anglais tout à l'heure
on verra si elle est au rendez-vous
alors au menu il y a aussi notre astuce
du jour astuce du chef c'est un autre
rendez-vous régulier dans le 7 8 ce soir
c'est de la poitrine de porc confite
avec poulpe et chorizo grillé et c'est
proposé par le chef Armindo macano
Machado de l'auberge humanet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui vous livre
tous ces secrets voilà le menu est connu
la table est dressée il est temps de
vous installer confortablement pour ce 7
8 qui débute tout de suite avec la météo
de demain
et c'est un premier jour de mars
ensoleillé dans le département mais il
fera encore froid le matin avec des
températures nulles ou négatives et 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan et
moins 1 degré à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi même condition avec un
Mercure qui monte légèrement compter 7
degrés dans le Nord et le Sud des
Yvelines 6 degrés à Houdan et Versailles
et ce mercredi 1er mars c'est la Saint
Aubin le point présent sur les
informations du jour de ce mardi 28
février c'est avec Michael el midoro
après deux années de disette dû à la
crise sanitaire les touristes étrangers
ont rapporté 58 milliards d'euros en
2022 à la France un chiffre qui bat le
précédent record de plus d'un milliard
dans les Yvelines le château de
Versailles et le site touristique qui a
attiré le plus de touristes en 2022 avec
6,9 millions de visiteurs un chiffre
néanmoins en baisse de 16% par rapport à
2019 les touristes étrangers viennent
principalement des États-Unis d'Ital les
visiteurs asiatiques n'ont pas encore
fait leur grand retour la Corée du Sud
premier pays d'Asie dans le classement
ne représente que 3% de la fréquentation
du site en 2022 la SNCF recrute en 2023
plus de 900 agents seront recrutés cette
année par Transilien SNCF voyageur dont
400 conducteurs de train RER et de tram
train et 200 chargés de la relation
client en gare de forum de recrutement
seront lancés en mars et en avril par
Transilien en Île-de-France SNCF
voyageur représente 6000 trains qui
circulent chaque jour dans la région
francilienne si vous habitez
saint-jean-en-laye que vous êtes éloigné
de l'emploi mais avec un projet de
création d'entreprise la ruche peut vous
aider le réseau national d'incubateurs
d'entreprise lance pour la troisième
année consécutive son programme le coup
d'envoi il permettra plusieurs lauréats
d'être accompagné pendant 6 mois
gratuitement à la création d'entreprise
vous avez jusqu'au 12 mars prochain pour
déposer vos candidatures les
inscriptions sont désormais close 12600
sportifs participeront la 16e édition de
l'éco-trail de Paris le 18 mars prochain
au programme 5 trails et deux marches
Nord iques l'épreuve parle 80 km partira
de l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour rejoindre
le premier étage de la Tour Eiffel
mauvaise opération pour le FC Versailles
les joueurs de la cité royale se sont
inclinés 1-0 sur leur pelouse face à
Concarneau le but a été inscrit en fin
de match par Faïd el Koumi Steve versa
également terminé la rencontre à 10
suite au carton rouge de Gustave
aquessen au classement les ivinois
perdent la première place au profit de
Martigues
[Musique]
et comme d'habitude si près de chez vous
vous êtes témoin d'une information d'un
fait qui vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas
à le dire sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news on a vu
dans nos informations du jour des
chiffres records en matière de tourisme
une année 2022 qui est reparti à la
hausse dans ce secteur ça a été aussi le
cas du côté de la Bergerie Nationale
effectivement le dernier record si on
peut pas appeler ça un record c'était
2017 et effectivement cette année nous
avons passé le cap des 122
000 visiteurs donc forcément une année
on va dire de respiration après les les
deux années covid qui ont été très
compliquées pour le site on a été
beaucoup fermé comme beaucoup de
structures touristiques ça fait pas mal
repris en 2021 mais effectivement en
2022 c'était vraiment une très bonne
édition vous avez fait partie des
touristes du château de Versailles ou de
la Bergerie Nationale en 2022 Véronique
non non
en tout cas une belle année en matière
de tourisme en Île-de-France et dans les
Yunes alors dans l'actualité également
il y a toujours la réforme des retraites
après les députés le projet de loi était
examiné depuis aujourd'hui par les
sénateurs à une semaine un de cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation qui
s'annonce très suivi l'une des
difficultés du débat sur les retraites
c'est que partant pourtant des mêmes
chiffres les économistes eux-mêmes sont
divisés il y a ceux qui sont favorables
à la réforme mais ceux qui s'y opposent
pour Véronique Jérôme c'est divergence
ne sont pas très étonnantes parce que si
les économistes utilisent le même
thermomètre ils ne regardent pas les
températures de la même façon
explication
[Musique]
que se cache-t-il derrière les
expertises des économistes on entend
dire parfois que l'économie c'est cette
expert qui sera parfaitement vous
expliquer demain pourquoi ce qu'il avait
prévu hier ne s'est pas produit
aujourd'hui plus sérieusement les
économistes baptistes diverses
expertises à l'aide d'une démarche
scientifique mais pour qui les écoute ce
choix crée l'embarras difficile de
trancher et de trouver des réponses
définitives c'est très forme des
retraites est-elle ou non opportune
comment faire pourquoi la faire la
crédibilité de la société savante des
économistes vacille des diagnostics
dissonants conduisent à des
préconisations discordantes on a pour
habitude d'observer que chaque courant
de la pensée économique s'efforce d'être
politiquement compatibles ainsi en
général un discours libéral qui met en
avant les vertus du marché sera
appréciée par un courant de droite alors
que la gauche met sa confiance dans les
partisans de l'intervention de l'État
dans l'économie
le centre va osciller entre ces deux
options quant à l'idéologie néomarxiste
elle a pour habitude d'exiger de taxer
toujours plus le capital revenons en
retraite l'opportunité de la réforme est
largement établie elle n'est rejetée
qu'au nom d'une trop grande injustice
dénoncée par les économistes qui
s'affichent gauche compatibles pour la
plupart il y a aussi une quasi unanimité
médiatique sur la défense du système par
répartition une dose de capitalisation
est une option évoquée par certains
libéraux mais c'est inconcevable de la
part de ceux qui dénoncent la tyrannie
des marchés financiers enfin la nature
de la réforme a un temps fait débat le
rapport Tyrol Blanchard était pour une
réforme systémique universalité et
justice d'un système par point le
politique s'est résigné et à trancher en
faveur d'une réforme paramétrique les
économistes de la direction du Trésor
approuve cette réforme dans une vision
macro comptable ou finalement le recul
de l'âge vaut pour la diminution des
déficits ainsi forcé de constater que la
querelle vient de ce que les experts
bien qu'il donne l'impression d'utiliser
tous le même thermomètre ici l'analyse
économique n'indique pas les mêmes
mesures de la température ambiante parce
que ces experts appartiennent à
différents courants de la pensée
économique même s'il s'accorde sur le
chiffre a annoncé la température disant
il fait 30 degrés alors constat et leur
conclusion vont diverger c'est un peu
comme si certains mesurait en Celsius et
d'autres en Fahrenheit ainsi il ne faut
pas s'étonner que certains nous disent
il fait chaud il fait 30 degrés Celsius
et conseil d'ouvrir le parasol quand
d'autres nous disent il fait froid 30
degrés Fahrenheit parce que c'est -1
degré Celsius et conseil de faire un feu
il ne me reste qu'à souhaiter que les
économistes entretiennent cette
diversité des expertises car si le choix
cré e l'embarras avoir l'embarras du
choix et préférable le pluralisme des
idées commande que les théories
continuent de débattre entre elles et
finalement l'économiste pourra se borner
à produire et proposer des expertises
variées et plausibles car en démocratie
ce sont les électeurs qui choisissent
les décideurs politiques qui décident
pour eux disaient en substance un Nobel
d'économie chance Buchanan
[Musique]
d'une Véronique à une autre la
transition était toute faite pour vos
insolites Véronique Ithurbide
et vous faites dans le bilingue pour
débuter avec
uropéen protocoling preventive
concevation pardon pour l'action anglais
autrement dit les picots c'est plus
simple comme ça on va dire les
médicaments
il s'agit d'un programme innovant qui
analyse l'impact du changement
climatique sur les
œuvres et sur les décors des demeures
historiques et s'intéresse évidemment au
premier lieu le château de Versailles
bien sûr alors j'ai eu au téléphone le
responsable de ce programme il s'appelle
Danilo forleo c'est un expert en la
matière il est chargé de mettre en place
une charte qui va avoir le jour
normalement enfin débauche de Chartres
en 2025 et pour cela il faut donc
analyser l'état des
œuvres et surtout comprendre comment
remédier à ce réchauffement climatique
qui impacte de plus en plus voilà après
c'est un double challenge parce que il
faut il faut préserver enfin éviter un
réchauffement climatique et en même
temps ne pas trop utiliser du coup de
machine qui vont faire
c'est beaucoup trop d'énergie alors il
faut aussi peut-être revenir à des à des
méthodes de bon sens il parle de
méthodes frugales je vous voulez des
exemples ou
c'est sur
quoi ou quoi et bien allons-y sur les
exemples on y va alors par exemple et
bien des tissus muséologiques en fait
sont des tissus techniques qui sont
évidemment des reconstitutions de tissus
mais
intrinsèquement fabriqué de sorte à
éviter les effets nocifs du soleil une
trop grande lumière etc après vous avez
aussi des trous de buée alors ça c'est
surtout au Portugal m'a dit Danielo
forleo mais il y en a aussi quelques
fois sur les fenêtres du château c'est
en fait pour éviter la condensation
il y a un petit trou l'eau s'écoule
gentiment et après ne va pas sur une
rainure et ne va pas aller abîmer les
boiseries de la fenêtre par exemple mais
alors on sait très bien mais ça peut
aussi et de l'air trop froid ou trop
chaud alors enfin c'est très très
délicat très minutieux donc il travaille
en corrélation avec le réseau des
résidences royales européennes donc là
il s'échangent les informations tout un
tas de statistiques pour mettre en place
d'une méthodologie efficace ils ont
travaillé avec Turin et avec la Pologne
là les prochains ça va être le château
de Chantilly et le Palais Princier de
Monaco voilà
il faut regarder les symptômes donc en
fait la chaleur fait que il y a des
insectes qui s'installent dans les
boiseries de la moisissure on croit que
qu'il y ait trop de publics c'est
mauvais mais finalement ça peut brasser
l'air et ça permet d'éviter les
moisissures il y a tout un tas de
paramètres à prendre en compte à
analyser pour après
prendre une belle charte 2025 qui
servira à tous les châteaux musées et
collections d'Europe
transition énergétique aussi
technologique d'ailleurs vous êtes très
technologies ce soir
à la fin de l'actualité du futur et vous
allez nous parler maintenant d'une
start-up qui a inventé des nouvelles
plantes génétiquement de modifier qui
purifient l'air c'est quoi le nom de
cette start-up plante elle s'appelle
cette start-up elle a été très très
aidée par la Région Île-de-France ils se
sont deux deux chercheurs qui s'appelle
Lionel Mora et Patrick Orbec qui ont eu
cette idée géniale ils ont été ils ont
profité des infrastructures des
laboratoires de Saclay d'accord et puis
de bref tout ce qui avait là-bas et ils
ont trouvé alors il s'appelle poto cette
plante quand vous tapez potos vous
verrez c'est une pente que tout le monde
connaît elle est très très commune alors
évidemment ils lui ont modifié son il
est en modifié l'ADN pour qu'elle puisse
capter le CO2 et les quatre principaux
polluants de l'ère intérieur
imaginez-vous parce que c'est pour
purifier l'air intérieur et jusqu'à
présent il y a déjà des plantes qui
existent mais qui se passe super
efficaces celle-ci elle va être vraiment
du tonnerre de Dieu mais alors le seul
truc c'est que bon ça y est elle est
elle est elle est conçue si je puis dire
mais en France on est soumis à la
Constitution européenne pour avoir un
agrément pour vendre un produit donc ils
pourront la développer en France que de
dans trois ans et demi ou 4 ans de temps
d'avoir l'agrément européen parce que
c'est aussi une question de vote c'est
pas que scientifique alors qu'en
revanche aux États-Unis c'est juste
scientifique ils prennent pas c'est donc
là ils vont justement commercialiser aux
États-Unis pour démarrer puisque ils ont
beau être à Saint-Ouen avoir laboratoire
à Saint-Ouen peuvent pas se permettre
d'attendre quatre ans avant de vendre ce
produit voilà donc cette plante elle est
absolument incroyablement géniale et
c'est pas très scientifique de dire ça
mais c'est pas grave et eux ils veulent
après travailler encore plus largement
sur la qualité de l'air et le climat
sortir un peu de l'intérieur mais déjà
si on dépollue l'intérieur c'est extra
c'est déjà extra on prend les agendas
pour pour terminer avec une
avant-première ça se passe jeudi
prochain oui c'est bientôt c'est jeudi à
20h30 au Cyrano à Versailles alors vous
connaissez que Xavier de Lausanne
vous allez connaître c'est
un documentariste très talentueux que
moi j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer pour
deux VIP c'était les enfants valises et
après je l'ai reçu pour
9 jours à documentaire sur une jeune
femme un Mustapha qui était la première
mère de de j'ai envie de dire Kaboul je
sais pas maintenant droit qu'à je peux
être médias pardon et elle a elle a 30
ans elle était la mère de racaille sa
mission c'était pas très compliqué
c'était reconstruire la ville donc elle
a réussi à imposer son autorité et dans
ce monde d'homme donc ça en fait c'est
une trilogie sur la vie après daesh qui
a entrepris de filmer Xavier de Lausanne
donc 9 jours à RACA cet effet s'est fait
en 21 et la sort cette fameuse
avant-première en toute liberté une
virgule une radio pour la paix vous avez
donc je dis demain ça 20h30 il y a une
présentation avec Xavier de Lausanne le
réalisateur et il reste après le film
n'est pas très long un peu plus d'une
heure et il reste après pour un débat et
alors Xavier de Lausanne il a filmé 7
jeunes journalistes qui sont aussi bien
musulmans chrétiens que yezidy et qui
vont tendre leur micro
aux gens qui veulent la paix c'est
vraiment donner la parole on va regarder
un extrait de la bande-annonce d'accord
comme ça on se fait une idée du film
[Musique]
et voilà donc ça c'est le deuxième film
de la trilogie et le troisième sortira
bien sûr après bientôt ça s'appelle
Mossoul campus ce sera à propos de
d'étudiants à la Bibliothèque
Universitaire de Mossoul qui se sort de
forum pour parler de leurs rêves de
leurs histoires enfin voilà et le don
qu'a Xavier de Lausanne c'est toujours
de parler de petits miracles d'humanité
qu'il va déceler comme ça dans des dans
des
situations très chaotiques et très très
compliquée et ça donne de l'espoir que
c'est beau et intéressant voilà première
ce jeudi du côté du cinéma Le cyano à
Versailles il y a une information qui a
retenu plus votre attention qu'une autre
les plantes peut-être
le potos développé par cette start-up
française
on l'espère de voir le projet émerger en
Europe merci Véronique en tout cas pour
pour ces idées insolites et on se
retrouve dans deux semaines pour les
prochaines pour les prochaines vidéos
insolites autour du département des
Yvelines à présent une une renaissance
on va parler d'une renaissance dans
cette é pour le club le village de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux la structure la
structure sportive a fait peau neuve
après trois ans de fermeture de
nouvelles activités comme le foot à 5 et
le paddle font leur apparition le
responsable des activités a fait la
visite en avant-première à Julien le roi
avant l'ouverture au public demain
[Musique]
bonjour Bienvenue au club le village
donc là on se trouve dans l'entrée la
zone vraiment le hall d'entrée il y a
également un petit espace donc bar
snacking
donc trois terrains de squash donc il se
trouve juste au niveau de l'accueil
passons un peu à l'anglaise avec les
tribunes pour tout ce qui sera un peu
compétition événement que nous
proposerons nous voici à l'étage
l'espace qui sera le dédié à la fitness
au cours collectif
[Musique]
maintenant à l'espace accueil nous
arrivons sur l'espace raquette tennis
badminton donc en soi comme vous pouvez
le voir c'est deux terrains de tennis
qui sont modulables en terrain badminton
donc on a fait le choix de vous proposer
un terrain de tennis et 4 terrains de
badminton qui se trouve un peu plus sur
votre droite
on a deux nouvelles activités présentes
sur sur le complexe où nous avons trois
nouveautés flambant neuf de foot à 5
voilà c'est une discipline qui se passe
dans un espace clos qui se joue à 55
dans l'idéal et la deuxième activité
c'est le tennis padel parce qu'on se
retrouve en fait dans un espace
également clos fermé par des fenêtres
sur un format terrain de tennis avec un
filet au milieu le terrain est plus
petit qu'un terrain de tennis
l'ouverture du complexe au public c'est
mercredi 1er mars à midi
[Musique]
bon si vous n'avez pas à l'âme sportive
et que vous êtes plutôt jeux La Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet vous propose
une sorte de Cluedo géant on peut le
dire c'est l'enquête à la ferme qui se
déroule du 18 février donc ça a déjà
commencé c'est jusqu'au 5 mars jusqu'à
la fin de ses vacances d'hiver Frédéric
Drieu vous êtes avec nous pour parler de
ce sujet et vous allez faire appel donc
au super enquêteur enfant et adultes
pour démêler de nouveaux mystères on a
commencé un peu à présenter le pitch
tout à l'heure en fait il y a un voleur
qui s'est introduit et a volé un dossier
confidentiel sur sur vos meilleurs
animaux il pourrait d'ailleurs revenir
un sur place pour peut-être tenter de
voler des animaux donc le but c'est de
l'en empêcher exactement effectivement
il a pas été malin comme vous le dites
instinct tu es d'où l'idée c'est de
retrouver ce voleur donc les enfants
sont accueillis par le commissaire en
chef et qui présente le sujet qui
délivre à chaque enfant un petit livret
et les enfants doivent ensuite aller
dans différents lieux de la ferme à la
bien sûr à la découverte des animaux et
en même temps ils sont accueillis par un
commissaire
qui qui leur explique ce que le voleur a
tenté de faire dans chaque dans chaque
bâtiment effectivement l'objectif c'est
d'expliquer à la fois les origines et le
projet d'établissement de la bergerie de
façon ludique donc je donne quelques
exemples chez le mérinos de Rambouillet
l'animal emblématique l'idée c'est de
comprendre en quoi la laine de ce mouton
et est exceptionnel et de comprendre les
différentes étapes du travail de la
laine nous passons chez les vaches
laitières et les nous produisons à peu
près 7000 yaourts par jour donc l'idée
c'est d'expliquer un peu le processus et
d'expliquer comment une vache fait du
lait et et les raisons pour laquelle
elle le fait et en même temps on
découvre d'autres choses dans la
basse-cour ou dans la chèvrerie le tour
en s'amusant vous l'avez dit c'est de
découvrir de manière ludique puisque en
plus de ça il va y avoir des énigmes
tout au long du parcours le voleur a
laissé des indices en fait dans chaque
bâtiment il a laissé un vêtement donc
l'idée c'est de retrouver un peu comme
le principe du Kies c'est de retrouver
tous ces vêtements et de retrouver à la
fin le commissaire avec ces éléments ces
indices qui vous permettra du coup à
l'enfant de déterminer le le bon voleur
c'est une enquête qui a déjà démarré ça
ça trouve son succès parce que vous
l'aviez déjà proposé sur d'autres
périodes de vacances
thématiques du mois du mois de février
donc la première semaine a plutôt bien
fonctionné très bien démarré là il fait
un peu froid les gens sont peut-être un
peu moins moins présents mais la
première semaine les deux premiers jours
on a eu à peu près 500 à 600 personnes
les après midi donc c'est beaucoup de
travail mais mais ça se passe plutôt
bien il y a beaucoup de monde pour
accueillir les enfants et on circule sur
une bonne partie de la Bergerie
Nationale sur toute la ferme voilà
effectivement l'idée c'est vraiment de
justement de répartir les gens sur
l'intégralité de la ferme et d'éviter
justement c'est c'est c'est
regroupements et de permettre
principalement de découvrir les animaux
de façon ludique tout en comprenant le
projet d'établissement de la bergerie
qui est orienté sur le bien-être animal
une agriculture respectueuse de
l'environnement et du consommateur on
retrouve bien sûr tous les tarifs aussi
pour les informations concernant la
réservation faut réserver pour venir
avant où on peut obligatoire
il y a d'autres animations aussi les
animations habituelles qui se déroulent
en ce moment à la Bergerie Nationale du
coup là les vacances sont vraiment
thématisées après on a d'autres
événements à la fin de l'année à la
pardon à la fin du à la fin du mois on a
le spectacle immersif que nous
organisons pour la première fois cette
année vous me faites vous me tendez la
paire vous faites la transition va
parler justement de ce spectacle
immersif qui est autour du thème des
bergers et ce sera tout de suite
maintenant c'est tout de suite dans
notre page culture qu'on va ouvrir à
présent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais bien sûr prévu d'en parler
Frédéric Rieu ça s'appelle l'école des
bergers
qui est proposé donc par la Bergerie
Nationale ce sera donc mercredi 29 mars
samedi 1er avril et dimanche 2 avril là
aussi un pitch pour pour démarrer cette
entretien autour de ce spectacle c'est
des spectateurs qui vont intégrer
directement une promotion de 20 nouveaux
élèves de la toute nouvelle école
nationale d'élevage ovins pour se former
au métier de berger et nous sommes en
1938 tout à fait effectivement on a
choisi cette époque tout simplement
parce que c'était le début de la
carrière d'un du dernier maître berger
vraiment important de la bergerie qui
s'appelait André Moret qui a formé pas
loin de 3000 élèves et effectivement on
va suivre un peu tout le processus de
scolarisation du coût des des élèves sur
sur un créneau qui va dur à peu près
deux heures donc c'est vraiment à la
fois immersif mais surtout très
participatif et le public pourra
les individuels qui seront du coup
considérés comme des élèves pourront
travailler le chien de berger manipuler
la laine aller dans un dans une prairie
déterminée l'alimentation des moutons
par un petit travail sur la botanique
nourrir les animaux voilà tout ça ça va
durer à peu près une heure et demie et
l'idée c'est de voilà le côté un peu
original c'est de la dernière séance
c'est de monter dans une calèche et
finalement de par une sorte de de jeu de
lumière c'est de Ré atterrir en 2023 et
d'expliquer que finalement la bergerie
depuis sa création en 1786 et depuis la
création de l'école de berger ça a
toujours été un lieu de un lieu de
formation et en 2023 effectivement nous
formons plus tout à fait l'héberger
comme on pouvait le faire il y a 50 ans
mais nous formons encore des élèves dans
le dans le cadre du milieu agricole donc
finalement on va découvrir l'histoire de
la Bergerie Nationale l'histoire du
métier de berger qui s'est
professionnalisé aussi un petit à petit
que un métier hérité de de vieilles
traditions mais qui a su se
professionnalisé avec le temps aussi et
voilà effectivement voilà il y a les
différentes séquences vont vous
présenter le travail du chêne berger
effectivement l'évolution ont travaillé
effectivement il y a il y a une
cinquantaine d'années avec le Beauceron
maintenant avec une autre race de chien
qui est le Border Collie ont tombé
effectivement avec des forces maintenant
il y a la tondeuse électrique la
manipulation du mouton effectivement
pour son bien-être au moment de la tombe
donc il y a des choses qui ont évolué le
tri de la laine la filière laine etc
tout ça c'est effectivement des choses
qui ont évolué et beaucoup dans le cadre
du travail proposé par la Bergerie
Nationale je vous ai vu acquiescer sur
André Moret c'est notre ami on en a
parlé
voilà
son passé plus 3000 élèves bergers
vraiment emblématique un personnage
célèbre qui a côtoyé le général de
Gaulle qui a côtoyé plein de plein
d'autres présidents et qui vraiment a
été une référence au sein de la bergerie
pour pour tout ce qui a pu être voilà
son enseignement et puis c'est vraiment
immersif ce spectacle là on est vraiment
dans la participation des spectateurs
c'est que à la fin de ce spectacle il va
falloir valider ses acquis avec les
épreuves théoriques pratiques pour
obtenir son diplôme de berger en quelque
sorte du coup tout au long du processus
on
aura donné un petit livret et les les
élèves de rombes répondre à des QCM
remplir un herbier expliquer le travail
du tri de la laine effectivement donc il
y a la fin André Moret va regarder le ce
petit livret et va le valider et
j'espère que tout le monde pourra
récupérer son diplôme comment ça s'est
préparé vous allez travailler avec des
comédiens professionnels ça est vraiment
ça c'est un projet interne à la bergerie
avant tout interne mais effectivement on
a sollicité des volontaires donc on a
fait un appel au peuple de Rambouillet
et de ses alentours il en a récupéré une
cinquantaine de personnes motivées pour
participer à la fois pour être guide
pour être acteur principal secondaire
figurant nous aider sur la technique
donc c'est un vrai projet en plus
collectif et vos je vous avoue très
sympathique à imaginer et on est
toujours bien sûr dans dans cet axe
pédagogique de dire que à la bergerie il
y a un axe formation bien sûr on en
avait parlé notamment avec Gabriel cal
qui sont arrivés deux élèves apprentis
bergers qui sont arrivés en finale des
eaux vampires des jeunes bergers qui
s'est tenu d'ailleurs la finale
nationale à l'occasion du Salon de
l'Agriculture alors pour les infos
pratiques au niveau des tarifs à 15
euros à partir de 13 ans et si ça douze
ans c'est 8 € gratuit pour les moins de
6 ans pareil j'imagine il faut quand
même réserver sa place par contre là il
faut réserver puisque du coup ce sont
des créneaux qui durent 2h mais pour que
pour 20 une vingtaine d'élèves quoi donc
pas plus pas moins donc et c'est surtout
par rapport à la capacité aussi de la
calèche du coup il faut vraiment
réserver ces obligations et toutes les
informations bien sûr sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
Frédéric Delrieu d'être venu en parler
en plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
responsable de l'équipe animation à la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet la
France est championne du monde
d'improvisation junior les jeunes de
Déclic Théâtre ont été sacrés face à la
Suisse le Québec et à la Belgique lors
d'une finale qui s'est déroulée la
finale du mondial devant une salle
comble à la Meurice de Trappes pendant 4
jours les délégations se sont affrontés
lors de match d'impro ou la bonne humeur
a prévalu sur le résultat retour sur la
finale avec Régine raleche la voix de
Céline Charles junior
explosion de joie pour la compagnie
Déclic Théâtre représentante de la
France elle a remporté la septième
édition du Mondial d'impro face au
Québec ce dimanche 26 février je suis
fière de mes jeunes c'est vrai après on
aurait vraiment aimé que tout le monde
puisse repartir avec la coupe parce
qu'on a vraiment vécu 4 jours hyper
intenses on est très très content
surtout que bah on s'y attendait
vraiment pas on a repris du plaisir à
jouer avec les Québécois et c'est vrai
que c'était un étonnement nous on
voulait on avait aucun but de gagner ou
de remporter une Coupe et là on a un peu
étonné mais bon tout le monde est
content on a passé un très bon moment et
puis voilà c'est c'est super alors je
suis très très fier de mon métier on a
fait 4 super beau match mais évidemment
final la France a juste été incroyable
il mérite la victoire aux côtés de la
France le Québec la Suisse et la
Belgique la consigne simple une
thématique une durée limitée
catégorie libre durée de cette
improvisation 2 minutes
au coup de siffler les équipes se
lancent dans des jeux d'improvisation et
mettre leurs talent à l'épreuve
[Musique]
durant près de trois heures les équipes
se sont affrontées dans la joie et la
bonne humeur au programme danse chant
humour tout pour ravir le public
ma sœur
est impliquée dans l'improvisation mais
je ne t'ai jamais allé voir mais ça m'a
bien pris en tout cas oui on a bien
rigolé on a on s'est beaucoup amusé
ouais cette année l'événement a fait
sale comble près de 400 places ont été
vendues la prochaine édition aura lieu
au Québec qui pourra peut-être prendre
sa revanche
[Applaudissements]
bravo à cette équipe de France junior
d'improvisation qui a remporté le
Mondial on va parler à présent musique
dans ce 7 8 turn over avec de nouveaux
invités qui m'ont rejoint en plateau
Audrey Brohan bonsoir de l'association
la voie en scène organisatrice du
tremplin à la 8e saison à livrer son
verdict avec trois vainqueurs de des
vainqueurs d'ailleurs sont avec nous en
plateau c'est Léon c'est soul bonsoir
bonsoir et on va faire votre
connaissance tout à l'heure prendre
aussi vos impressions suite à cette
victoire et autour de la table également
il y a Christine paloé et Jean-Marie
Guynemer bonsoir alors vous venez parler
vous du festival électro chic la
septième édition va bientôt démarrer
alors juste pour vous présenter
Jean-Marie guynevert vous êtes directeur
des affaires culturelles de la ville de
Versailles et Christine Pallot
directrice à la culture de
l'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc
alors d'électro on en parle justement
aussi avec cette information juste avant
de parler d'électrochimique la
billetterie de l'événement Versailles
électro est ouvert depuis ce midi ce
sera le samedi 27 mai dans les jardins
du château de Versailles en tête
d'affiche on peut voir juste l'animation
s'afficher de la du côté de la régie et
il y aura Martin Solveig et kungs alors
on me dit qu'on ne l'a pas en régie
juste pour vous préciser que le prix des
places va de 45 à 250 € et que les
informations et la réservation est à
faire du côté du site du château de
Versailles spectacle alors on parle d'un
autre événement là on parlait de
Versailles électron on parle bien
d'électrochimique à présent juste avant
de parler du tremplin des voies c'est un
événement qui prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur d’années en année et cette
septième édition va réunir 23 artistes
dans huit communes de Versailles Grand
Parc ce sera sur deux weekends du 9 au
18 mars c'est une septième édition qui
se démarque des autres ou finalement
dans la continuité de ce qui a pu se
faire dans dans les éditions précédentes
Christine Pallot on est dans la
continuité de ce qui de ce qu'on
développe au fur et à mesure des années
avec des artistes de renommée
internationale qui viennent d'un peu
partout dans le monde et puis aussi des
jeunes artistes que qu'on tâche révéler
ou au travers du Tremplin ou dans la
programmation des artistes différents on
découvre aussi peut-être différentes
branches de la musique
électrochimique depuis le départ c'est
précisément d'être représentatif autant
que faire ce peu de toutes les
esthétiques de l'électro il y a
énormément de choses le point de départ
c'était évidemment la Versailles touch
donc l'électro à la française qui est né
à Versailles ne l'oublions pas et sur le
territoire du Grand Journal
tous les autres oui mais pas Daft punker
par contre c'est bien vrai c'est
également le cas de bien des eaux de
Arnaud robotcigny enfin ils ont tous
fait ils ont tous quasiment beaucoup
Toyer sur les bandes du mamie c'est
Jules Ferry c'est dire si leur proximité
est grande
mais cette pour le coup pour ce qui est
de Daft Punk c'est non voilà tous les
autres c'est oui et précisément cet
appuyé sur cette antériorité cette
histoire pour il y a 7 ans de ça
maintenant puisque c'est la c'est la 8
ans de ça même c'est la septième édition
pour justement régénérer cette acquis
cette histoire mais assez merveilleuse
quand même qui fait que des des gamins
c'était tous des lycéens de Jules Ferry
un moment donné se sont mis à faire dans
leur cave avec deux trois beatbox mets
de la musique complètement nouvelle qui
nous a tous marqué on a tous donc enfin
tous en tout cas ma génération on a tous
dansé sur sur effectivement sur R et
quelques autres morceaux de légende et
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est précisément de
renouer avec cette légende mais avec des
jeunes talents d'accord deux jeunes
talents des jeunes et moins jeunes mais
surtout de continuer à servir de
tremplin sur le territoire à deux jeunes
talents sur une aire géographique de
plus en plus large puisque au début on
était grosso modo sur trois communes et
là on est sur 8 communes donc chaque
année il y en a une de plus quasiment on
va parler de la programmation dans un
sens juste faire un petit tour de table
électro c'est une musique qui vous plaît
ou enfin vous en écoutez régulièrement
Audrey Brohan ben du coup j'accompagne
de plus en plus d'artistes qui ont un
petit mélange électro parce que par
exemple j'ai une artiste qui est électro
afro donc voilà avec un DJ avec un
guitariste et et voilà donc il peut y
avoir des influences électro dans vos
musiques par exemple à vous sous le 11
pas du tout mais un peu de tout c'est je
m'inspire un peu tout je chante ça
m'intéresser un peu à tous les styles et
puis voilà de m'imprégner un peu de
chaque influence mais c'est vrai qu'avec
maintenant les plateformes on a accès
vraiment à tout type de musique et on
s'arrête plus du tout
au style et donc oui moi c'est vrai que
je m'influence je mon influence elle est
vraiment de partout et notamment de
l'électro d'ailleurs pour le festival
électrochic est-ce que ça s'adresse à
des passionnés d'électro ou même des non
initiés peuvent venir sur place en fait
on est vraiment ouvert à tous types de
public on a même y compris des
masterclasses pour des gamins qui ont
qui ont 6 7 ans donc on commence très
jeune c'est comme ça que ça commence
c'est comme ça que ça commence non tout
c'est vraiment tout public alors
effectivement la variété de la
programmation fait qu'on peut se rester
à des publics qui sont vraiment des
pointus et des fans et puis des gens qui
ont honnêtement ils connaissent rien
voire même son on peut parfois aller de
l’électro sur quasiment l'électro pop on
traitait le cas par exemple en 2018
quand on a fait venir l'impératrice au
mont entier on est sur vraiment une
grande diversité d'esthétique pour
précisément toucher capter le maximum de
de public alors pour faire une idée on
va écouter tout de suite un petit medley
des artistes qui seront à l'affiche de
ce festival électro chicette
[Musique]
un petit échantillon ce qu'on disait à
23 artistes qui sont programmés on
entend bien cette mélange des
esthétiques dans un même festival
serment le Paris parce qu'effectivement
la plupart des festivals électro
choisissent une ligne très très
caractéristique le pari qui a été fait
depuis le départ ils étaient
particulièrement le l'objet de nos
discussions nos premières discussions
avec Joël gainsburger qui est le patron
de Londres et avec lequel on a créé ce
festival il y a 20 ans 8 ans c'était
précisément d'arriver à avoir cette
diversité des esthétique qui était aussi
romantique de la diversité des villes
participantes et chaque villa s'aligne
quelque part et Christine Pallot c'est
aussi important Jean-Marie Guilbert le
disait tout à l'heure de mettre en avant
si la jeunesse les jeunes talents
puisque on va parler de quelques têtes
d'affiches mais il y a quand même des
jeunes artistes c'est eux qui sont mis
en avant aussi au travers ce festival on
des jeunes artistes qui viennent des
tremplins des années précédentes et
certains qui viennent et reviennent qui
ont grandi et qu'on continue à valoriser
accompagner et puis effectivement on a
d'autres d'autres têtes d'affiches
peut-être parmi ces jeunes aussi montrer
là on a vu des images enfin écoutez
Olympe 4000 on a une place des
compositrices et des DJ femmes très
importants dans la programmation de
cette année on l'a pas forcément fait
exprès c'est la réalité de la création
artistique d'aujourd'hui et puis on est
vraiment ravis d'accueillir Irène
driesel qui a été récompensé vendredi
soir pour la meilleure musique de film
par par les César donc voilà c'est c'est
super pour cette valorisation de ces
artistes là jeunes et moins jeunes
artiste femme aussi qui sont de plus en
plus de place dans cette scène électro
des noms alors mb14 peut-être qui parle
un peu plus au grand monde je vois ceux
qui acquiesce principalement connu sur
le beatbox aussi hein exactement c'était
aussi l'un des paris c'est de s'ouvrir à
ce type d'esthétique là on est vraiment
dans l'électro pour autant mais c'est
vrai que c'est la première fois fois
qu'on a ce type d'artistes dans la
programmation on espère qu'ils vont
cartonner on est on est précisément au
Palais des Congrès parce qu'on fait le
pari du carton donc on est dans une
grande salle c'est aussi les premières
fois que le c'est la première fois que
le Palais des Congrès de Versailles
participe en tant que programmateur et
sale au festival électrochim donc c'est
pour nous doublement une première et là
on reste complètement dans la ligne de
l'esthétique et de la de la
programmation d'électrochique ils seront
également suivis d'un groupe qui lui est
directement issu d'être en plein qui est
i am Sparrow qui sera programmé pour la
deuxième fois du coup parce que il y a
aussi une logique de suite par rapport à
cet alors là c'est qu'on peut les
retrouver deux ans trois ans plus tard
d'accord et les voir grandissent les
entendre grandir les voir grandir au
sein d'électrochimique exactement alors
il y a aussi alors on revient à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure le mélange
des styles aussi on peut mélanger
l'électro hip-hop notamment la fine
équipe qui vont être présents à Chaville
le le 10 mars juste sur les infos
pratiques est-ce que le billet forcément
les billets sont à apprendre à l'avance
Christine Pallot il vaut mieux parce
certaines salles qui commencent à se
remplir très très vite mais bon enfin
voilà il y a vraiment des formats très
différents des tarifs très variables
aussi en tout cas le moyen de passer une
excellente soirée
à tous les coups la fourchette de prix à
peu près pour avoir une place et 25 €
franchement c'est vraiment très
accessible et toute la programmation sur
festival électro chic point fr le site
bien sûr qu'il s'agit en bas de l'écran
donc je rappelle les dates du 9 au 18
mars 8 communes de Versailles Grand Parc
on a compris que c'est un festival qui a
s'étendait à de plus en plus de communes
de l'agglomération info et raisins sur
le lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
la dernière question que j'ai envie de
vous poser petit tour de table je vais
vous donner chacun la parole les
ingrédients d'une édition une septième
édition réussie Christine Palois la
complicité entre les partenaires
Jean-Marie Guilbert la diversité des
talents qui s'exprime
voilà donc tout est tout est dit avant
le début de ce festival
électro il a déjà eu des artistes
électro à l'avant en scène vous le
disiez qui mêlait justement peut-être
différents univers on peut le comprendre
aussi
pas trop après il y a mais parce que il
y a comment dire l'utilisation voilà
l'utilisation de de pédales et tout ça
donc cette année je crois qu'il y a une
candidate qui utilisait beaucoup les
pédales pour faire ça et puis il y avait
un DJ sur un autre groupe aussi donc
c'est souvent mixé en fait
acoustique et DJ il y a vraiment ce
mélange de plus en plus dans les projets
alors on parle avec vous trois de la
finale de 7/8 saison du tremplin des
voix c'est le 11 février dernier du côté
de la Maison de l'environnement et de
Magny-les-Hameaux 22 candidats c'est
bien ça qui a été donc en lice et si on
peut rappeler le concept du tremplin des
voies donc il y a eu différentes étapes
et aussi différentes catégories pour ces
candidats c'est ça du coup il y a des
gens comité d'écoute les sélections Jam
les auditions les demi-finales et donc
la finale avant la finale windique
c'était un bon cru cette huitième saison
est-ce que vous confirmez après la
finale est-ce que la finale a été un bon
moment à vivre la finale a été
exceptionnelle c'est vrai que tous les
ans on dit plus ou moins la même chose
mais c'est vrai que cette année c'était
quand même assez fort en émotion
au niveau vraiment des artistes c'était
vraiment très difficile quand même ça
s'est joué de peu pour beaucoup et voilà
vraiment une belle panel d'artistes et
d'ailleurs c'était on va dire la
première édition normale après la
période covid ça faisait aussi du bien
on imagine de retrouver une sale comble
un public
c'est une bonne nouvelle après même si
nous ça nous fait toujours un peu mal au
cœur de dire aux gens qui arrivent de
jeûne CESU et ben non vous pouvez pas
rentrer mais ça nous fait plaisir d'être
revenu à ce là parce qu'on s'est dit bon
c'est un programme qui plaît toujours et
du coup voilà les gens ont envie de
venir découvrir des artistes et voilà
donc
on est super contents et je le disais
vous êtes venus avec deux des trois
lauréats de ce tremplin des voies saison
8 il y a tout à gauche de la table soul
qui a été vaincu dans la catégorie 18
ans et plus et aussi qui a été lauré du
prix du public et à côté de vous sollia
Léon ce qui a été vainqueur du Prix
auteur compositeur interprète selon on
va commencer avec vous qu'est-ce que ça
vous fait d'être justement lauréat l'un
des lauréats de ce tremplin des voies
saison 8
c'est une immense fierté déjà parce que
j'ai beaucoup travaillé là-dessus j'ai
j'ai l'habitude de faire des concours
avec différents registres que je mets en
valeur j'essaie de me tester sur sur
plein de choses et ce qui me manquait un
petit peu là où je restais un peu amerte
et sur le fait de pas avoir réussi à
aller au bout d'un concours que j'avais
fait précédemment
pour une cause de registre et je voulais
pas que ce soit une excuse donc voilà
j'ai pu rectifier le tir et passer un
bon moment et aussi comme on dit qui
fait ce que je fais voilà les 11 c'est
pas beau que ça vous fait d’être lauréat
beaucoup de beaucoup de joie beaucoup de
de reconnaissance envers le tremplin
aussi Qui est qui a réussi je trouve à
malgré que le fait que ce soit un
concours et qu'il est un gagnant et des
perdants on a quand même vécu une
expérience forte très humaine et ils ont
réussi à justement à
gommer un peu cette esprit un peu de de
guéguerre quoi
donc voilà je voulais les remercier pour
ça beaucoup et pour pour l'expérience et
la chance que j'ai eu aussi de finir ici
et pour la cité elle n'est pas avec nous
en plateau il y a Clémentine aussi qui a
été lauréate dans la catégorie moins de
18 ans vous disiez un concours qui a été
très serré cette année qu'est-ce qui a
fait la différence justement pour ces
trois artistes
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence sur
ces trois artistes je pense peut-être la
mise en pratique du travail qu'on a fait
avec eux de toute la préparation enfin
je pense que c'est peut-être qu'ils ont
réussi à se lâcher vraiment et à
partager au maximum leur univers avec le
public je pense que c'est c'est vraiment
ça qui pouvait faire la différence et la
gestion un peu de de son stress et de
comment on le partage avec l'autre et je
pense qu'il
en fait c'était assez intense en termes
de don de soi même si ça a été sur trois
jours au final
ça a été un peu speed parce que il y a
eu beaucoup de candidats à orienter à
coacher et ce qui est bien c'est que bah
on a chacun une autre moment où on a eu
de l'attention sur nous et on pouvait
mettre en pratique ce qu'on nous ce que
nous apprenait au niveau des coachings
donc voilà on va faire votre
connaissance en quelques mots l'univers
sol qu'est-ce que c'est
je dirais que c'est bah déjà de la sole
mais c'est aussi plein de choses
différentes c'est tout ce que j'ai
écouté depuis que je suis petit
et c'est surtout ce que je ressens et je
pense que le plus important c'est que
quand je chante les gens puissent savoir
ce que je ressens aussi voilà on va
écouter un extrait de votre prestation
en finale
ce que tu es le pire ce côté
de ses mains
[Musique]
en plus de ça vous avez eu le prix du
public justement d'avoir eu l'adhésion
en quelque sorte du public puisque
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait ça c'est
d'autant plus une fierté et je cesserai
pas de le dire je suis vraiment
reconnaissant parce que avoir deux fois
la reconnaissance du public sur un sur
un tel concours c'est
j'ai conscience que c'est une chance
c'est que c'est aussi pas rien donc
voilà je tiens aussi à remercier aussi
des gens qui ont qui ont voté pour moi
et
qui ont connu mon travail Léon sauvoue
c'est le prix donc pour la catégorie
hauteur compositeur interprète pareil
même question pour sol pour ceux qui ne
vous connaissent pas quel est votre
univers
chanson française
pop acoustique
poétique avec des inspirations peut-être
oui bah comme je disais inspiration un
peu de tout genre mais si je devais me
comparer je dirais influence pomme
Vianney Ben Mazué et pareil on va
écouter un extrait de votre prestation
finale
[Musique]
au cher et tendre
et douce viande
[Musique]
à croquer
osez
aux écueillir le fruit de la fleur
[Musique]
c'est quoi le titre de cette musique et
alors vous l'aviez écrite spécialement
pour le tremplin ou c'était ça faisait
partie déjà de votre répertoire oui oui
ça faisait partie de mon répertoire mais
je l'avais pas vraiment joué sur scène
parce que aussi ce qui est formidable
avec ce tremplin c'est que à en finale
on a accompagné par des musiciens en
live et à vrai dire ce morceau j'avais
pas vraiment d'idée d'arrangement donc
je me suis dit pourquoi pas proposer ce
titre et voir qu'est-ce que les
musiciens vont me proposer et l'ambiance
et la couleur que ils vont pouvoir
apporter et je peux dire que j'ai pas
été déçu et que vraiment les musiciens
étaient vraiment rendez vous et à
l'écoute de la chanson une découverte de
le faire en live avec d'autres avec des
musiciens jusqu'à présent j'étais dans
ma chambre en guitare voix ce qui est ce
qui est très agréable mais à plusieurs
et de le partager depuis de voir la
chanson prendre une note dimension c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très sympa juste
pour présenter parce qu'elle est pas
présente plus grand au plateau
Clémentine qui est lauréate dans la
catégorie des moins de 18 ans qui est
elle Clémentine alors Clémentine elle a
ce qui est marrante c'est que Clémentine
a démarré toute petite je me rappelle
que en 2017 2018 j'ai retrouvé des
candidatures de clémentine une petite
jeune 10 ans 9 ans avec sa guitare comme
ça qui se présentait pour la première
fois au tremplin des voix et chaque
année en fait elle représentait sa
candidature et elle passait pas toujours
les étapes d'ailleurs parce que voilà et
de l'avoir en finale gagner la finale
l'année dernière elle est en demi-finale
par exemple ben je trouve vraiment ça
génial parce qu'elle a bossé d'année en
année et puis là elle est dans une école
de comédie musicale à Paris
et du coup ça elle a elle a elle a
travaillé sur son univers justement pour
nous apporter vraiment une belle
interprétation elle elle est vraiment
elle est vraiment à fond dans
l'interprétation dans le partage avec le
public aussi donc je pense que c'est ce
qui a fait la différence
pas le temps de l'écouter mais en allant
sur le replay de la soirée il y a toute
la soirée qui est disponible sur le
compte de la voix en scène du tremplin
des voies sur le compte de la voix en
scène sur YouTube
et qu'est-ce qui va se passer maintenant
pour eux du coup comme ils sont à
lauréat
on essaye de de leur apporter différents
outils puis ils ont gagné pas mal de
choses donc voilà ils vont rencontrer
des professionnels ils vont enregistrer
ils vont résidence enfin voilà on est en
train de voir un petit peu enfin un
premier étape c'est de voir quels sont
leurs objectifs aussi de savoir c'est
quoi
ce qu'ils imaginent pour leur avenir
demain et de voir dans ce cadre-là
comment on peut les accompagner au mieux
c'est rapidement vos objectifs justement
la suite pour vous sol alors moi au
niveau personnel je bosse sur un sur un
projet avec des chansons anglaises je
bosse aussi sur des chansons à côté en
français et j'espère sortir ça
rapidement et que bah ça trouvera
son public les onces
moi je sortirai fin septembre début
octobre
a EP
et puis je sors une petite reprise de
chansons sur Instagram une fois par
semaine bon en tout cas bravo et bonne
chance pour la suite de votre parcours
musical merci d'avoir été avec nous pour
parler de cette huitième saison du
tremplin des bois
et avant de se quitter comme chaque
mardi l'astuce du chef pour briller en
cuisine ça a peut-être donné fin à nos
invités autour de la table de la
poitrine de porc confite poulpe et
chorizo grillées c'est le chef Armindo
Machado de l'Auberge du Manet à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui vous livre
ses secrets dans la studios du chef
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Armando Machado je
suis chef de cuisine à l'auberge du
madère Montigny-le-Bretonneux je vais
vous présenter aujourd'hui une recette
de poitrine de porc confite avec poule
péchorizo que nous avons actuellement à
la carte c'est parti
[Musique]
alors l'astuce pour cette assiette elle
est au sujet du poulpe pour cuire le
poulpe il faut d'abord le surgeler de
façon à ce qu'il ne soit pas trop dur et
que il soit bien moelleux à la cuisson
et ne puisse pas trop longtemps bon
appétit
[Musique]
j'ai vu des réactions mitigées en
plateau il y a la team pool et ceux qui
n'aiment pas le pool en tout cas merci à
Armindo Machado pour cette nouvelle
astuce du chef on va jeter un dernier
coup d'oeil avant de se quitter à la
météo de demain
avec un premier jour du mois de mars
ensoleillé dans le département il fera
froid cependant le matin avec des
températures nulles ou négatives 0° à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et Houdan -
1° à Rambouillet dans l'après-midi même
condition avec un Mercure qui monte
légèrement compter 7 degrés dans le Nord
et le Sud des Yvelines 6 degrés à Houdan
reversailles ce mercredi 1er mars c'est
la Saint Aubin voilà c'est la fin de ce
7 8 merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
également à nos invités à d'avoir été
avec nous autour de cette table et
demain vous retrouverez Mathilde Franco
à la présentation d'une nouvelle édition
belle soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]